there's this [ __ ] store in knock on
broadway that's like right at the
entrance of knock on broadway that sell
uh gengars from anime and like they sell
like cells from anime
right and like oh i saw that one yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] and some of the
some of these cells i mean like some of
these cells are quite cheap because they
probably would like mass produced or
just based on shows that no one really
cares about but some of the more
expensive ones are just like
holy [ __ ] yeah i remember there was a
cell from the end of evangelion
that i saw from the it's it's in the top
floor of nakano broadway if i remember
correctly and it's
right at the back um but they have some
like really classic cells the most
impressive one i saw was
one from like the end of evangelion and
it was the oscar fight as well
and it was it was an expensive boy yeah
how much was
it it was like i think it was over like
ten thousand dollars yeah
that that sounds about right yeah i mean
for a piece of paper i mean at that
point it's basically like a museum
yeah yeah yeah how can you put a price
how do they get that
how does that like get in the hands of
somebody is it like maybe they like sell
those off in like auctions maybe someone
like maybe some staff member takes it
and then they sell it all
like there's only one zelda oh no like
hey man this crunch is brutal man i'm
gonna take a little something home
like make a little bit of cash on the
side like there's a snitch in the studio
taking out ourselves yeah but i think
they're only just gonna get more
expensive because now
animation studios don't you sell
animation anymore so right right
at this point it's just become like a
memorabilia right of history because you
can't
i mean you can get like gengas and
everything like that but you know having
a good old
fashioned cell is just because you can't
like unlike a genga you can't
like you know photocopy a cell right
because it's it's based off like a
plastic sheet
yeah right so it's much easier to tell
when a cell is completely fake because
i've seen some [ __ ] completely fake
cells yeah and it's just like on these
like flimsy pieces of paper and people
paint stupid amounts of money for it
because they don't know any better right
i'm just like no don't what are you
doing it's just a [ __ ] drawing
do you guys miss the old like cell
animation aesthetic compared to like
much
cleaner digital aesthetic of today
it's bittersweet for me i think like
right obviously like you know the
digital stuff now
is like so much better choreographed
yeah like the later ends like you can
tell that like oh these camera movements
were done
through a computer yeah but i don't know
there's something really charming about
like
you know a manual like camera shake
edda nettie great animation
[Music]
dude man i love that love the bubbly
lines you know i mean it's kind of it's
comfy it's kind of i mean no
i mean like redline was all uh
oh my god that took like what ten years
no seven years seven years
it took a little while but yet no one
[ __ ] watched it
yeah i mean i will say that i i think
you know on average
animation is is better quality now
because digital animation has made
things
has made it easier to get a higher level
quality of animation for like most anime
yeah
but yeah i think you're right there is
like like a definite charm
uh about watching good old-fashioned
style yeah i definitely wouldn't want
all my anime to be based off cells but
no there are some like especially like
when you go back to like you know the
whole like 80s just like general anime
aesthetic
yeah that like the oh yeah this is an
80s animated aesthetic like that on cell
animation is just
it's like a bowl of like rice krispies
you're like i never eat a [ __ ] bowl
of rice krispies
when i do i'm like all right okay that's
not bad okay
but then the next day you're like i
don't even think about rice krispies
that's how i sleep
you know what i mean
literally zero things about cereal i
don't eat cereal yeah like me neither
that's why it's like i should kind of
remind you being a kid again you know
what i mean
i don't fully agree i
reminds me of like a bowl of cereal
right like i never
i i don't eat cereal right frankly i
don't care
for it right there i said it okay
controversial